A few years ago,
a leading scientific company had a
specific challenge.
It was a toothpaste company and they
make different fluorides for their
toothpaste,
but there was a big mechanical problem.
The fluoride was getting stuck in the
equipment and it wasn't meshing well.
The company had engaged all their top
chemists to try to figure out what the
problem was and no one could solve it.
It was taking months and months and time
and costing hundreds of thousands of
dollars at that point.
So the executive on the team said,
you know what?
We have not been able to solve this.
Who else could we engage?
What other networks could help us solve
this problem?
So the company ended up posting this
fluoride challenge on a website called
Inno centive,
which is a community of crowdsource
scientists who come together to help
large companies solve scientific
challenges.
Within a few days of posting this
fluoride challenge,
a physicist who lived in Canada looked
at the problem online and said,
this isn't a chemistry problem.
It's a physics problem.
It's about charged particles.
You charge the fluoride one way the
toothpaste the other.
Instantly the problem was solved.
Colgate realized a few things from this
experience.
The first thing is that they never even
dare to ask the physicists at their own
company because they had labeled it as a
chemistry problem.
The other thing they realize is that
physicists that solved the problem may
have never been hired by colgate.
He didn't have the traditional resume.
He had had different careers throughout
his life,
and so in today's world,
we can access and engage expertise in a
radically different way to find real
time solutions,
and those that may have the answers are
those that choose to contribute.
They may not be who we suspect are the
right people to contribute.
In my book,
get big things done,
the power of connectional intelligence,
my coauthor Nicole,
Joe and I and I distilled connectional
intelligence into five specific traits.
We looked at companies and leaders
around the world and found that there
were specific skillsets that you could
use to build your own connectional
intelligence,
and they are called the five c's of
connectional intelligence.
The first C is curiosity and we all
think about curiosity is the ability to
ask great questions,
but from a connectional intelligence
perspective,
curiosity is the ability to design your
questions so that other networks outside
of your own can engage to help you solve
those problems.
So if you think about when you're
solving a problem today,
how can you not only be curious to ask
who you traditionally go to,
but how might you design your question
to engage a new community at different
resource and outside perspective from
another company or even outside your
industry that could lead to a new and
different breakthrough solution.
The second C of intelligence is
combination and combination,
as we all know,
is the root of innovation.
Combining disparate ideas,
people and resources to come up with
something entirely new and different.
So as you think about combination,
how are you leveraging your combination
skills of different resources within
your company,
across teams,
across business units,
at different levels in different regions
of the organization and far beyond with
companies and customers and other
stakeholders that could help create and
forge new business solutions,
new opportunities,
and address challenges that you may be
facing.
The third C of connectional intelligence
is courage and we all know that courage
is such a key part of all of all of the
key ways of connecting.
And when I define courage from a
connectional intelligence perspective,
it's really the ability to be able to
have difficult in different types of
conversations,
but not just raise those conversations,
being willing to amplify and sustain
them over time because we know that
having a onetime connection doesn't
create breakthroughs.
It's those people that are willing to be
courageous to continue those
conversations over time.
Often it could take years to really lead
to that breakthrough,
but it's that sustaining of the
courageous conversation that creates
that.
So as you think about your own courage,
how many courageous conversations are
you having every day?
Are you sustaining those conversations
over time and what might be those forms
or avenues that would allow you to
amplify your own courage?
Who Do you surround yourself with and
make connections with that makes you
courageous yourself?
The fourth C of connectional
intelligence is community and we all
know that community is such a big aspect
of this.
Finding different networks of people
that can care about similar things that
can spark ideas together.
And what we found with connectional
intelligence as those that really tap
into this superpower are those that see
communities far beyond traditional
forums far beyond the traditional
hierarchies.
So it could be a community of moms in
the company at Unilever that have a new
way of thinking about what their
customers might need.
Or it could be a network of Latino
employees at Frito lay who realize that
there's an opportunity for a guacamole,
doritos chips that turned into $100
million dollar product for the business.
So communities can be far beyond our
traditional spectrums of what people's
roles and traditional sources of
expertise are.
So as you think about your own
communities,
what communities are you involved with?
What informal formal communities,
what internal and external communities
do you engage with and how might you be
able to leverage them,
not just for what they're traditionally
known for,
but what other problems they could solve
for you,
for your team,
your company,
and beyond.
And the last C of connectional
intelligence is combustion.
So once you have courage,
curiosity,
community combination,
it's about how do you allow it to
mobilize income.
Bust combustion is the ability to
mobilize and curate your communities to
create added value.
So it's when you've built your
community,
it's when you've tapped into the courage
of that community that allows those
people to create value in a new and
different way.